die kreisstraße 30 zwischen kommunen und
dalberg in mecklenburg vorpommern ist
gesperrt
der grund diese marode brücke damit
wenigstens fußgänger und radfahrer die
strecke nutzen können hat die
straßenbaubehörde diesen provisorischen
holzsteg auf die brücke montiert das war
vor sage und schreibe 13 jahren
mittlerweile wachsen hier die bäume aus
dem asphalt
wir fühlen uns verarscht wird es immer
hieß jetzt geht die planung endlich los
und dann hört man wie gar nichts mehr
jedes mal vor der wahl wird uns wieder
versprochen die brücke wird gemacht und
bei mir ist eigentlich der punkt
erreicht wo ich glaube da nicht mehr
dran wenn ihr nichts passiert wird
hierbei arbeit sein
die brücke wird in den sechziger jahren
aus stahl und holz gebaut bei einer
routinemäßigen bauwerksprüfung 2005
werden schwere schäden festgestellt
holzpfähle sind verfault die gesamte
konstruktion könnte einbrechen
der landkreis sperrt die straße für den
autoverkehr allein fußgänger und
radfahrer kommen hier noch lang
doch die kreisstraße 30 ist in der
region eine wichtige verbindung muss ein
dalberger etwas im cramon erledigen
fährt er einen umweg von satten zehn
kilometern
tag für tag seit nunmehr 13 jahren die
bürgermeister der beiden betroffenen
gemeinden sind schwer
gefrustet das darf eigentlich nicht sein
dass so was so lange auf dem rücken
unserer einwohner und ein wahrer
ausgetragen wird
ich denke wenn diese straße in
gemeindehand gewesen wäre hätten würden
wir heute nicht stehen
wir haben so eine ähnliche baumaßnahme
vor zehn monaten in auftrag gegeben etwa
200 meter von hier
wir waren in einem vierteljahr fertig
beim zuständigen landkreis aber passiert
seit 13 jahren nix reparieren wolle man
nur wenn das land die hälfte der kosten
übernimmt bei bereitstellung von
fördermitteln soll die sanierung 2019
2020 erfolgen
ein antrag auf fördermittel wurde beim
straßenbauamt schwerin gestellt zur zeit
liegt noch kein
antwort vor das sich an diesem zustand
tatsächlich was ändern wird daran
glauben viele bürgerinnen und bürger
schon lange nicht mehr
leere versprechungen werden gemacht das
wird nicht eingehalten das ist schon
ärgerlich sie zu bringen uns nicht
weiter
die rocker sollen anrollen und sollen
endlich die brücke machen ob hier die
bagger bald anrollen werden weiß also
niemand so genau
vielleicht geht es aber rund um die
brücke zwischen cramon und dalberg auch
in die nächsten jahren eher im
schneckentempo weiter